how can we create internalized lasting
motivation for every day should
behaviors these are the things people
know they should be doing but just
struggle to muster the motivation to do
on a regular basis these images give you
examples of the many such behaviors
right save for the future donate to
charity read to your kids if you're a
parent eat healthfully take care of the
environment vote don't text while you're
driving that sort of thing and they also
represent by the way many of the pretty
serious and persistent social and policy
challenges that could be improved pretty
dramatically if we could find scalable
ways scalable and and low enough cost
that we could afford to scale them to
get people to change their behavior now
I'm not obviously close to the first
person to realize that we need to get
people to change their behavior these
are some of the are just a couple of the
huge number of examples of appeals
people see every day to change their
behavior
you can you exercise is medicine you can
beat diabetes by eating a healthy diet
we can save the environment by turning
off the lights one thing I want you to
notice the main thing I want you to
notice about these is that these are all
pragmatic appeals right they focus on
the self-interested or otherwise
pragmatic reason why people should
change their behavior and the problem
with that is that's telling the reader
why the person who made the appeal
thinks it's important or probably more
accurately the person who commissioned
commissioned the appeal but the problem
with that is that it it relies on
self-control or willpower to get people
to change their behavior and
psychologists have known for some time
this is not a domain you want to be
relying on right self-control and
willpower works sometimes in acute
situations it does not work for
sustained behavior change and so I've
been thinking a little bit about how to
sort of focus this question even even
more and and
and the the sort of focus version of the
question that I've been focusing on is
how can we get people to care about the
things they don't already care about but
should a couple of things I want you to
sort of keep in mind about should
behaviors one is this doesn't represent
the situation people know what the
responsible choice is they're not
they're not in doubt about that right
and so telling them or reminding them of
the pragmatic reasons why they should
change their behavior is unlikely to be
giving them new information so it's not
really clear even what the theory of
change is behind a pragmatic appeal
other things that are sort of a little
less sort of directly obvious are our
problems like myopia or intertemporal
discounting it's referred to in varying
ways depending on whether you're talking
to a psychologist or an economist but
the central idea there is that we over
value the immediate present and
undervalue the distant future and so as
with many should behaviors when a
behavior requires a sacrifice in the
immediate term in service of some
distant pragmatic goal the distant
pragmatic goal is unlikely to win that
fight relatedly but distinct is the
notion of procrastination which is
simply even if I do care about that
distant pragmatic goal there's rarely a
compelling reason for me to start
changing my behavior today rather than
tomorrow right and both of these pose
very serious challenges to Tibbett to
getting people to engage in should
behaviors and then the third important
thing to remember I guess it's the
fourth important thing I want to make
top of mind for you is that positive
impact for many of these behaviors
depends on sustain repeated change in
behavior and that's really important
because there's been a major and and
important movement in behavior change
recently called called nudge and most
people refer to it as nudge and it's the
idea that you can you can set up choice
environments so that the easiest thing
to do is the thing that's in most
people's best interest
and it's a huge innovation I think it's
it's probably the single most important
innovation and be in the science of
behavior change I don't know maybe ever
it's a hugely important innovation but
the problem the weakness of it is that
it's not very well suited to the sorts
of should behaviors that require
sustained change across a wide range of
contexts for the simple reason that we
don't have control over enough of the
context in which people are making
decisions right if you're trying to get
people to adopt healthy diets you might
be able to change the order of the menu
items at a restaurant but that's not
going to transform very many people's
lives because most people don't eat at
one restaurant all the time and so the
sort of complementary idea to nudge that
I've been working on with my
collaborators is something I'm calling
values alignment and the idea is to
identify existing strongly held and
widely shared values that the desired
behavior might serve and then frame
appeals for that behavior in terms of
how they might serve this alternative
value and so the idea is you're changing
how people think about the reason for
engaging in should behaviors it's it
becomes less about the distant pragmatic
outcome you're you're pursuing and more
about living in accordance with some
value that is important to you in the
immediate term and and so the idea here
sort of from a theoretical perspective I
talked about intertemporal discounting
this problem that the distant pragmatic
outcome just isn't a strong enough
motivator for people the idea of values
alignment is that you replace that
distant pragmatic outcome with an
immediate symbolic outcome the good
feeling of knowing you're being the kind
of person you know you feel you should
be being and when I say values I really
do mean values broadly construed right
what a person thinks is important in
life what has immediate motivational
force
[Music]